you know Eddie the description of the
prophet sallallaahu our ESL learners was
revealed in the taurah and you know it's
a beautiful author that you should read
after arm of the light nam of the last
Ravi Allah one woman but the prophets
description was revealed in the taurah
the wording is dear and one of his
attributes is al helm
what is it helm forbearance that
somebody harm you and he is deserving
your punishment and you're able to
punish you're aware of their horn and
you do not need them and you refrain
from punishing them and rather you treat
them kindly this is what helped the
prophets allah salem during his time
there was a jewish rabbi
his name was a dog no semina he said i
was able to verify every single
attribute of the prophet mentioned in
the Torah jewish rabbi the scholar wrote
a school he said I was able to verify
except this one that when you increase
dealing with him in an ignorant way his
forbearance increases so I decided to
test him in this area now he's going to
put him to the test yes how did from
subtle hacking for the those who want to
go and review it so he went to the
mosque one day when an incident happened
in front of him that some Muslims needed
desperately some financial help but was
also a lahar SLM asked Ali bin Abi Talib
rhodiola on whether we have anything to
give or not to give the group of Muslims
or not he said no Zayed no Ximena said
this is my chance so he went to the
Prophet Sawa Solomon said I will lend
you the money for one year of course no
use ok so after three months he came
back requesting his loan and he actually
proved the prophet of Allah from here
from his neck and he actually insulted
him and his tribe and this is a big know
in knock'em been wash empowerment look
you are the
been washing the
tryam of hash him mutton they don't you
don't pay back the he's really putting
to the test
oh yeah yeah and the Restless alum is
like you know standing on armor of
course was there an omen wanted to
interfere like he would normally do or a
salsa lala haria Selim said to her was
oh ma you should command him to request
his moon back in a better way and you
should encourage me to pay him back
maybe he's in need for the money maybe
look look at this they don't listen
nobody maybe he needed the money when he
given it to us he was you know better
off but now it's just a matter of so
asked me to pay him back
encouraged me to pay him back now please
take him and give him his loan back and
give him a name he wasn't like let's get
him you know everybody jump now no give
him an increase you know this man said a
shadow la ilaha illallah wa ashhadu anna
Kurosawa he said there's nothing where
they worship who said God Almighty Allah
the Creator it is a job the last thing I
was waiting for that to see your
forbearance
yeah ayyuhan nabi look at the verses in
the tower
yeah you Hannah be in our cell neck I
share hidden mobile share on one idea
this is in the book of Isaiah Oh
messenger we have sent you a bearer of
glad tidings and a Warner look at this
look at this
hell's a little mean security for the
illiterate look Lester be early even one
of them well as Harvin Phil as well
you're not harsh you're not tough and
you don't speak with noise you're not
loud your yoga layer zero kaljaa hello
allah Hilma when people treat you
ignorantly and increase in abusing you
because of their ignorance that only
increases you in forbearance we got to
come on brothers we'll say la ilaha
illallah muhammad rasool allah we gotta
act like muhammad rasulullah